hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to try not to laugh
cigarette yeah sometimes I'd like to
smoke down here okay I get replay on
that one I'm fine no no no we just we
just started we cannot be laughing this
early good god
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
why is that what that's not funny that
is not how is that funny in what world
[Music]
not funny not funny
[Applause]
[Music]
huh what up you fat piece of [ __ ] get
the [ __ ] off my property
scheisse haha that's just unexpected I
saw that mmm huh sorry I have something
in my so mean it's so mean you're a
meanie
and then again so you may read the law P
the quarterfinal serve your sentence
your stolen goods are know for it
and pay with your brand
[Music]
why oh I I haven't seen that wonderful
haven't seen them before this that'll be
fine just think of how delicious you're
gonna make a great sandwich
in fact I named you after your eventual
fate well we can't have the girl die so
how about the pig dies why is that guy
still wearing a plastic bag on his head
[Applause]
and though we'd eliminated the threat of
the enemy flying planes into buildings
no one was prepared for terrorists
flying two buildings into the size of
planes
[Music]
no one was killed but a lot of people
were surprised they did pull the gun on
me when I got back around the house
because I guess he thought I was upset
with him who steals a cheese grater he's
got the worst lifestyle he stoled an
empty bottle of spring what got me the
most was my soap
he stole my soap who steals soap
who steals so who does who what kind of
[ __ ] come on man that's not cool
don't do that don't do that stop it
get some help I swear I might have seen
that one before
I mean yes that is the way we do it in
America
it's gonna be horrific ly racist
knocking I have as a hi good and oh you
understand a sore my father you they are
such awesome mom so you wanna go in
darkness
[Music]
I hate or you
[Laughter]
[Music]
I'm sorry how little you care about your
audience I think you'll get a kick from
this I got hit by a car on the way to
work today what my 500 euro bike is
beyond repair my neck is stiff and I can
barely raise my arm but my boss made me
go to the doctors and I got the morning
off that's a win in my book dude you got
hit by a car that's not a win dude crazy
stories I'm going to work today and some
dumb ass cyclist pulls out in front of
me naturally I write them over these
[ __ ] so my mom was driving me home
from school today and the cyclist
swerved in front of us and we hit him
these goddamn cyclists fishing for
insurance money Hayden I'm so sorry that
that happened to you we're had so many
accidents with bikes today all around
the same time
funny story just watch some guy on the
street watch some biker get hit by some
car II complain about the cyclist as he
didn't help the poor man [ __ ] a funny
story I was on the porn set while this
fluffer was giving clearly a card
[Laughter]
clearly a [ __ ] car whose top deck eed
and wrecking wouldn't stop for some
[ __ ] gyro bikes today my landspeeder
went some little podracer so I ran him
over and then killed his family as he
looked on in horror Segal so I was
flying my usual today it's awesome do
you know the buddy get hit by a car
Stevie Wonder yo I
[Laughter]
it's a pile of bulls yeah yeah it is
yeah at all is because it was just
unexpected ought to be racist or
anything but
not to be racist or anything but Asians
not to be racist or anything
[Music]
I can't tell if like he was doing it as
a joke or if he really was passing out
and wiki cuz oh man that's gotta be back
alright well another day another loss
I have nothing important to say I have
nothing important to remind you of I
have nothing to say at all so if you
want more thank you everybody so much
for watching have a lovely day
and as always I'll see you in the next
video bye